[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
突然ですが家質問です
このフルーツ
この花見たことあるよっていう人手を挙げてください
意外といるありがとうございます
でもね実はねそんなにしてる人いないんですよね
私はこのフルーツを使って新しいカルチャーを広めようとしています
その新しいカルチャーはその名もジャグアートです
じゃぐゎーっていうのはフルーツの名称でこちらのこのデザインも先ほどの
オーガニックフルーツを使って施術をしています
パッと見はパターンに見えますが
実は違いがあるんです
タトゥーに見えるこのじゃぐゎーと
実は
全く痛みはありません
海外では医療目的であったり美容目的やそういったもので使われています
それ以外にも1週間ほどで
消えてしまうんです
この
じゃぐゎーと私は広めているのですがこのように書いていきます
普段紅茶ぐわーとをして
そしてデザインを洗い流すと
一時的に消えてしまいます
そこから24時間かけて色がふわーっと出てくるんです
そして2週間後には
少しずつ消えていきます
この
ジャグアートはこのようにしてデザインを少しずつ書いていきます
私はこのジャグァーとにすごく感動して教会であったりサロンの運営を今までしてき
ました
しかしこの仕事をしていると偏見がたくさんあるので強そうとか危なそうとか
そうやって
言われてしまいます
そのせいで
じゃぐゎーとの施術をする際にスペースを借りようとすると
姉だったら借りれるのに
じゃぐゎーとだったら断られることもすごく多いです
例外でも
ジャガーとしているっていうだけで
なんと
引っ越しも2回促されて追い出されています
それぐらいタトゥーに対してすごく偏見があるんですよね
足はそういうジャグワープが
どんどん広まってほしいって思うのに
なかなか偏見が取れが区定数を困っています
型にはめてくる人間が世の中にはたくさんいてそれでうすごく悲しむ人も沢山いて
なかなか言い出せないこともあるのに
いろいろ言われてそうやって悩む人がたくさんいると思うんです
そうやって
尻尾や消費する人生を送って
それを支えていきたい覆していきたいと思うんです
このだ西日本をジャガーとで覆していきたいと思っています
この今聴いてくれてる中の形で
ズーマーコミュニケーション取るのが苦手だなぁとか
例えば
いうのはそんな流外交的ではない内気だなっていう人ってどのくらいいますか
結構いますね私自身も実はあんまり
今までは
外向的ではなかったんです内気な方でした
でも自己表現って
実は言葉や行動だけではないと思うんですよね
ファッションやアートも自己表現の一つ一つだと思います
そういった意味ではジャガーとは
自己表現のひとつとして皆さんに使っていただけると思うんです
このようにアクセサリーとして使うこともできます
そうやって
ジャガーとを広めて今までたくさんの方がサロンにご来店されました
とある女性の話をさせてください
暖かい日のことでした
彼女は
大学生で
可愛いらしい華奢な方でした
しかし
気温は暖かいはずなのに
結構長袖を着てるんですよね
なんでかなーと思って手術どの部位にされますかって聞くと彼女は腕を指さしたんです
そして
私は腕をまくってもいいですかっていうふうに聞くと彼女
脱ごうになってしまいました
何かよ悪いことを言ったのかなとこうどうしてもかなぁと思って気になってたんですよ
ね
彼女にどうしましたかというふうに聞くと
彼女はこう言いました
実は腕がコンプレックスで
そう言うかそういうことかーと思って
私は腕を
見させていただいてもいいですかっていうふうに聞きました
そうすると彼女の腕には
リストカットの傷があったんですよね
ああそういうことかって思ったんですけど
私はこう聞きたいことや言いたいことをたくさんあったんですけど
その日は多くは話しませんでした
こないんじゃないかって思ってたんですけど
ここから枚付き彼女はジャガーとに来るようになったんです
嬉しいなぁと思いながら彼女には
少しずつ変化がありました
今までは
長袖しか来なかったのに夏になるにつれて少しずつ
七分袖半袖タンクトップ
どんどん袋の村袖の長さが変わってきたんですよね
それを見て私は
彼女の中のコンプレックスが
少しずつ薄れていって
身になっていってるんだなと思うようになりました
それに気づいたときに
私はこの仕事やってて良かったなあ
やりがいを感じるなっていうふうに思いました
こうやって聴いてくれてるの中の人でもいじめであったり挫折や悩んだことであったり
信託だった経験ってもしかしたらあるかもしれません
でもそういうストーリーをあああーーーーとにできるってめちゃくちゃかっこよくない
ですか
その人にしか出せないアートがあるんです
市はわー
そういう人にこそっちゃ区アートをしてほしいって思います
じゃぐゎーとにはいろんな意味があります
このように翼は自由や希望勇気であったり
つばめアトリは愛やコーン
信頼であったりそういった意味があります
チェックアートをしていると
そのデザインってどういうデザイナーのってどういう意味があるのって引かれることも
よくあります
そういう時にこう聞かれると
なんだかこう普段話せなかったことを話せるので
心の距離が少し縮まると思うんですよね
それ以外にもそのデザイン可愛いねかっこいいねって
そうやって言ってもらえるだけでなんか
認められたような気持ちになるんです
市は
をデザインこのジャガーとが広まっていくと
もっと生きやすくなって自己表現がしやすくなるんじゃないかなと思っています
カプルもそうです
lgbt などそういう偏見があったりとか
悩む
とって結構あると思うんですそういう時に使って頂けたらうれしいなって思います
氏自身今までジャガーとすることで
たくさん悩んできました
好きな事を仕事にしようとすると好きなことを仕事にできるのは一握りだよとか
飛び抜けた才能がないから難しいよーとか
そうやって否定の言葉を浴びて
不安になって
ストレスになって体調を崩してバイトも大学も休むことになって家賃も払えなくなって
全部放り投げて
せてしまった過去があります
それでも
こういう家をかけるように途中でやめることは今握っていることだとか
今頑張れないと何をしてもうまくいかないとかそうやって
全然根拠がないのに説得力のあるような言葉を浴びせられるんです
コレってどうなのかなって思うんですよね
でも
この19歳デージャグァ後初めて
今
この場に立てて
本当に嬉しく思っています
大邱アワーとは
皆さんの中でどういったイメージがあるでしょうかありますでしょうか
私はジャパンカルチャーにしたいっていう思いがあります
ただ
そこにはとても変形などが多いです
日本のカルチャーは
サーブと茶道や華道
書道も
日本の伝統舞踊もたくさんあります美しいものがたくさんあります
そのなかの1つに
弱アートが増えてもいいんじゃないかなと思うんです
今まで変形に対して
どういう向き合い方をしてきましたか
足は
今までここに対してすごく向き合ってきました
皆さんと
これから
ジャガーとで
自分らしい生き方を貫けるような
そういう世界を作っていきたいです
ジャガーとジャパンカルチャーに
ありがとうございました
[拍手]